eewan eewan McGruder yes I said II won
that's because you want no human no
could you imagine if you meant threw me
off like that you never know more so
even even even Keshia chante et Canada
anytime awesome you win yes nice to meet
you nice to meet you said that correctly
very good so doctor sleep is horrifying
The Shining is you know a classic and
everyone still says a lot of lines from
that film was it intimidating going into
making this well it was I don't think so
I mean I think because Stephen King
wrote follow-on novel yeah called doctor
sleepin and I think had he not done that
probably then you could feel pressure
about if you just if Hollywood decided
to make a sequel to to the shining then
I think maybe might might not be so
interested in it but because Stephen
King was who gave birth to it in the
first place - felt like he wanted to
take characters from The Shining novel
and write a new and take that story
forward into a different place then I
felt pretty I felt pretty okay about it
and then I met Mike Flanagan who's the
director who's who's who immediately I
felt a connection with and felt like he
had something interesting to say and
about it and and about the subject
matter of it I was interested it's also
very much about there's something about
Danny's character you know Danny's an
alcoholic and at the very beginning of
the story his at his lowest air but Rob
Bottin and and and soon finds a reason
to be to live in a new way and and finds
recovery and ends up in a sober life and
I
interesting to play yeah Kylie was
saying on set that you were practicing
your American accent and you're
fantastic oh well I think one use as
part of your as part of your character
so yeah you want to try and get that
right yeah I would I would yeah I I'm
not quite sure it's practicing but it's
trying to get it right do you feel just
so relieved to be able to talk about
obi-wan series now yeah just feels so
good
keeping it to yourself Oh a long time I
mean we've been talking about it for a
very long time and then it was just it
was just impossible not to you know
because everybody I was always asking
about it and I had to pretend that I
didn't know anything about it and it
started it was slightly humiliating
after a while you just think well I
don't know maybe people think that
they're thinking of someone else or I
don't know it was anyway so relief to
talk about it
did it feel good to hold the lightsaber
again I'm done it yet no well we haven't
shot it yet no we're shooting it next
year have you know practicing no just
kind of getting ready no yes no no yes
it's next year I don't need that much
practice to do the lightsaber but I'll
be okay
making this film did you have nightmares
do you have like active dreams no I
didn't I didn't I don't there's
something you know you're not trying to
make it you're not trying to you're not
focusing on the scariness of it I
suppose you're thinking about it from
the inside of the the person you're
playing and of course he has moments
where he's scared and certainly scared
of his of visions and nightmares but it
doesn't really transfer to me as such
yeah not really